eric zemmour ne s'aiment pas le trouble
que dans les sondages il le fait aussi
lors de ses déplacements
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'il se rendait bien sur la côte
basque et plus précisément à biarritz
pour présenter son livre plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont manifesté
pour dénoncer la venue du polémiste on
est là pour s'opposer
de l'autre sur place de nombreux
effectifs de police étaient présents
pour éviter tout débordement alors
manifestation boycotter débordements et
les émaux est il un danger pour l'ordre
public
merci d'être là les chéris merci raphaël
arnaud mais il tente hitachi ce qu'a
subi une agression par l'extrême droite
qui appelle à manifester contre eric
zemmour ce samedi alors non c'était le
samedi 23 octobre ce samedi dernier duc
la manifester contre les mélanges de
l'extrême droite d'accord et vidal rail
nouvelle la normalisation des discours
d'eric zemmour mais vraiment sur les
plateaux il y aura d'autres
manifestations de trouver simplement il
y aura d'autres initiatives évidemment à
chaque fois qu'on sera attaqué
directement par les propos violents
d'eric zemmour et d'autres personnages
d'extrême droite on sera présent à
chaque fois évidemment d'accord il ya
juliette briet brienne se dire rien à
rien excusez moi ça va influencer ce ce
patriote sava juliette à vous alors vous
êtes contente eric zemmour à 17 % dans
les sondages la vie un ou des croyances
un sondage où ils ont coûté oui je pense
que connaissent les sondages en tout cas
prouve qu'il ya une vraie dynamique en
sa faveur vous le connaissez vous régler
mon les yeux doux non pas du tout à vous
le soutenez vous le connaissez pas du
tout la connaître oui c'est fou ça je
crois que vous lui aviez vous espérez
rien du tout ah non non j'ai fait rien
moi j'espère juste que la france a
vraiment va gagner ouais moi je me suis
vous connaissiez peut-être c'était pour
avoir un truc après non non non c'est
fou ça ministre de la culture il la
connaît même pas pour l'instant juliette
n'ont peut-être qui la connaître alors
c'est vrai que là en ce moment il ya un
déferlement en fait et c'est vrai que là
plein de gens qui ne veulent plus d'eric
zemmour pour ses meetings est ce que
vous comprenez ça eux gibert des tout à
fait moi je réponds oui c'est un danger
pour l'ordre public parce qu'ils
professent la haine en fait et donc il
veut fracturé la société qui veut
cristalliser des oui contre des noms et
il se repaît de ces débordements il se
repaît de ces manifestations moi
franchement vu ce qui se passe je suis
pour qu'on l'interdise de discours
pendant un moment
alors j'ai manqué face
à la prendre comme excuse moi ceux qui
viennent manifester pour le coup c'est
des gens plutôt de gauche et qui veulent
couper la parole à ce mec on est en
démocratie se désole il ya des meetings
à faire si on n'aime pas il ya une
réponse c'est un bulletin de vote robert
lorenz candidats non mais non non mais
peu importe tu peux pas dire ça mais
vous dites gdt son discours il a un
discours haineux c'est vrai il des
choses épouvantables mais plus on va
aller faire du bruit autour de ses
meetings conclure on va dire que l'on va
hurler forte voix à venir insulter évite
les gens qui le respectent et plus ils
peuvent apprendre des voix les caméras
de m6 sont allés à la rencontre des fans
d'eric zemmour à biarritz qui était venu
pour ça ces séances de dédicaces vous
allez voir qu'ils n'ont pas été tendres
avec les manifestants
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que vous
pensez des manifestants qui vous eu qui
sont idiots et jo parce que je suis
homosexuel et je vote pour zemmour alors
je les emmerde est ce que vous pensez de
ce comité d'accueil
je pense que vous êtes des fascistes et
que vous leur répondez qu'ils sont des
connards comment on fait pour se parler
on ne peut pas parler avec ses jardins
c'est une bonne question du journaliste
la raison c'est vrai juliette oui ça
où donc est l'examen est il un danger
pour l'ordre public moi ça me fait un
peu rire déjà parce que vous mettez face
à quelqu'un quand même qui fait partie
du groupe en fils inventif a donc c'est
un peu fort de café venant d'un groupe
de racailles littéralement de rachat
permettrait prévention la circulation
quand on subit on puisse vous insulter
ou militants c'est nous qui avons
sortis des gares donc s'il vous plaît
aux quatre coins des mémoires à lyon
parce que j'ai pu faire ce que ces anti
fahey lyon c'est un groupe ultra violent
de racailles je vais juste terminé 2ème
les sessions avec papa et maman
tranquillement région le leader des
leaders amassé unis
en fait promeut directement sur ces
réseaux le groupe djihadiste boko haram
vous vous souvenez cette histoire
d'accord non médical présent vous devez
avoir eh ben vous dites quoi alors les
favoris pour éric thériault lui défend
un groupe djihadiste ou terroristes
justement jaillet j'allais y aller a
lancé par fait par l'anti terrorisme on
a des gens comme eric zemmour qui
s'érige en tant que figure contre le
terrorisme noah la jeune garde
on lutte contre le terrorisme nous il ya
déjà là et complétée en réinjectant n'a
pas de théorie déjà des camara qui sont
allés lutter a dit laura de notre
organisation contre des ch en syrie
d'accord mais pour bloquer des camarades
arabe kurde lisible qui ont fait reculer
dèche
chez les hommes aiment évincé d'axa
c'est mon corps politique hyper c'est
comme anti terroriste et donc c'est
pourquoi avons-nous valide s'il ya des
discours comme eric zemmour notamment
avec des tests comme le grand
emplacement qui poussent des militants
d'extrême droite notamment un mini
toques séquelles qui s'appelle logan
nisine il a eu un procès lui
contrairement à veut dire on ne sait pas
d'où ça valait rien
complétée par militants formés à
l'action française un groupuscule
royalistes profondément antisémite qui
est d'ailleurs avec très proche des
délégués moore et compagnie rassurez
vous savez sa solution politique c'est
passer aux attentats terroristes lui
avec tout ce corpus idéologique là il
s'est dit avec ses petits copains on va
attaquer des muscles on va attaquer des
mosquées on va attaquer jean luc
mélenchon il a dès lors été impérial n'a
rien de dix ans que je dirige zemmour et
le nom des gens vous le dire c'est
qu'ils ont dû mieux s'amuser notamment
comme le remplacement pousse des gens
aujourd'hui aux attentes ans et ça c'est
très grave on va ça va très très grave
un titre qui pourrait pousser les gens
aux attentes avoue caillassé je vais
profiter en entier origin va combattre
ce que
j'essaie de dire que eric zemmour en
même temps sur le sujet ça n'a rien à
voir avec eric zemmour vous vous
caillassé du cateau du flic métier
souvent et des métiers mais at home in
my mind envoie station ce samedi 23 mai
et à visage découvert pendant un petit
copain devant leurs locaux étaient eric
vérité
dont les volontés des jeunes tout ce qui
bouge georgie rue l'exemple
zemmour trouble leurs brebis bajon c'est
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
pourquoi à chaque fois qu'eric zemmour
se déplacent pourquoi il crée des
émeutes pourquoi il se fait insulter la
réponse est simple parce que ses idées
sont nauséabondes et qu'elle divise la
société
au bout d'un moment quand on passe son
temps à dire qu'à des bons des mauvais
et étranger qu'il faut pas s'appeler
mohamed il faut interdire le mariage aux
homosexuels etc il faut passer
délégitimiser la violence légitime pas
la violence si on en entend parler d'ici
au nom du soldat contre l'eire on
laisser parler les gens c'est pat la
violence peut délirer physique mais elle
peut être aussi verbale et je pense
qu'avec les idées d'eric zemmour il ya
des millions de gens qui se sentent
agressés au plus profond d'eux mêmes
donc je ne cautionne pas la violence il
faut pas s'étonner quand on dit des
trucs de ouf tout le temps à la télé et
dans les discours que quand on va au
contact des gens il se passe des choses
que vous cautionnez est-ce que vous
cautionnez l'agression qui a eu lieu à
toulouse de militants jay z totalement
pacifique est en train de coller des
affiches et qui se faisait agresser par
des racailles avec des couteaux est ce
que vous le cautionner parce que votre
votre ami à côté de la commune aucune
vieux sur sur twitter il a mentionné
cette agression mais moi je brûle
jeunes et vieux locaux sinon d'un combat
qui s'appelle olivier marc à la flèche
un club de gym
organisation dissoute récemment
génération identitaire existe toujours
dans le vieux lyon qui est une zone de
non droit ce concert 15 milliards la
sambre accès aux zones de non-droit
utilisent des
centaines de mineurs au sol c'est ça les
détend et vous connaissez vous plaît
s'il vous plaît mais là faut pas qu'on
va pas rentrer dans ton amour va pas
rentrer dans votre débat on parle des
labs et mauve et jaune elles font la pub
d'eric zemmour me pourrir et géraldine
maillet il peut faire c'est juliette
gérad email sur le fond je suis vraiment
d'accord avec benjamin oui évidemment
eric zemmour il est clivant il assume il
va d'ailleurs faire passer marine le pen
pour une socialiste féministe et
progressiste donc franchement là il y va
extrême droite extrême droite extrême
droite et pour le coup enfin il faut pas
victimiser aller voter contre lui
monsieur oui ça sert à rien fait de ma
mère il faut pas le maillot n'est en
fait fait lui eric zemmour me
semble-t-il c'est un danger pour l'ordre
public non ce qui est un danger pour
l'ordre public c'est la précarité c'est
le chômage c'est l'insécurité c'est les
zones de non droit c'est le trafic de
drogue c'est alors seulement que ça
c'est un danger pour l'ordre nordiques
et lui finalement savez je trouve que
c'est quand même un déni de la réalité
de plein de gens qui ressentent tous ces
problèmes et en gros on leur dit
attendez vous vous êtes un danger pour
la république de penser comme zemmour
pense voyez ce que je veux dire alors
regardez regardez tout mauvais les gens
ont souvent du mal à dialoguer quand il
s'agit d'eric zemmour ça commence
calmement puis le ton est toujours très
vite regarde
il sait mourir fouroux qu'il essaye de
faire son petit chemin en main et un sur
tous les plateaux télé et en dilapidant
son venait chez vous y retournez chez
vous nous c'est ça vous dérange de voir
zemmour
oui je viens pour là pour mes
petits-enfants croyez vous que je viens
zemmour ce petit
rien pour nous je m'attends pas mal au
cul te dire ça tu viens pour te faisais
d'enfants si ça le premier jeu
vous demander si vous voulez de
tranquillement 2 voilà on va éviter un
peu en échange est tranquille et
l'aurait forcée à faire la même chose
pour macron parce que quand même
marseille on nettoie sûr on enlève et
puis si on enlève tout mais l'on repeint
tout aussi nous il se fait gifler il se
prend d eux sur avec nos mémoires non
excusez moi c'est à dire que tous les
hommes politiques aujourd'hui non mais
tous les hommes politiques aujourd'hui
sont extrêmement
les troupes au palais au palais alors là
le maire de biarritz qui a rod a refusé
d'accueillir eric zemmour paul la route
où le journaliste elle ci a été lui
demander pourquoi regarder au vu de la
date puisque nous sommes en pleines
vacances scolaires je me suis opposé à
ce que ce meeting se tiennent en plein
centre-ville j'avais peur qu au milieu
des familles qui viennent souvent avec
les grands parents on se retrouve avec
éventuellement voilà des échauffourées
et le commissaire m'a dit qu'au vu de ce
qui s'était passé dans d'autres villes
nous pouvions avoir effectivement des
manifestations de protestation
alors est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
le maire de biarritz à la mer de
biarritz victime a dû cavaler révélé non
parce que typiquement ne fait que le
renforcer en euros dans la machine on
met un euro dans le nourrain c'est à
dire que les gens quand on quand on dit
quand il imagine qu'on le bayonne parce
que c'est ce qu'ils imaginent parce
qu'ici hold my hand c'est qu'il a des
choses à dire et qu'on veut pas qu'on
les entende nous donc pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne peut pas entendre ces choses là
qu'est ce qui se passe on ne parle pas
de ses idées
l'idée n'est pas de le bâillonner et
force est de constater qu'aucun de ses
meetings ne repose sur la sérénité il ya
toujours des choses et c'est totalement
je sais quel moment ça va faire je la
bats
les couilles quand il faire sinon il
fait ses news avec jean marc morandini
tu es obligé déployé des forces n'ont
[Applaudissements]
pas envie de déployer tous leurs moyens
pour assurer
si on fait avec on s'en fout là debout
mais oui les jeux d'ego mais il arrive
il revient
il était au bowling à une heure que
selon gala
traumatise pas il est revenue la toile à
son poids il a fait son poignet il l'a
fait quand même à fait d'accord alors
elle va dans les carrefours sur les
parkings de carpooling zemor les actions
à nos toits juillet bien il allège mais
je vais donner la chance à bernard
montiel parce que c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui fait une très mauvaise
émission avoir cédé affectionne
intelligent ce soir maire de biarritz
est dans son droit spécial n'est pas
encore candidat officiel donc elle a le
droit de le refuser on peut pas lui
reprocher est encore actif en wikipedia
une future de la loi et non c'est
intéressant de savoir ça mais une fois
qu'il sera candidat à l'élection
présidentielle elle ne pourra pas le
refuser mais voilà maintenant que c'est
important de savoir dans buzz comme on
dit du coup on déroule le thème après
les autres attaquants tonton les gens
dire que c'est juste le renforcer quand
tous là justement je l'étais d'accord
avec cissé j'allais revenir dessus il ya
un personnage qui s'appelle dieudonné
met notamment son petit copain alain
soral qui a été condamné fermement pour
ça les composantes imite la lune
m'autorise pas ça me fait du bien tant
mieux que ce personnage soit condamné
comment ça se fait que lors eric zemmour
il a été condamné aussi eric zemmour a
été condamné notamment de froid haine
raciale etc eric zemmour c'est un
personnage qui à la télé devant tout le
monde sans complexe fait du
négationnisme en disant que la france
n'a pas joué de rôle notamment envers
les juifs
il va pas vraiment d
extrême droite qui ont emmené des juifs
dans des camps était originaire de petit
peu on continue à semer soit parce qu'il
est juif qui peut être antisémite
donc en fait tu voulais dire c'est pas
parce que juste qu'il peut pas être
antisémite tout à fait pour me prêter
des parents qui sont totalement fausses
et bien non c'est pas vraiment le
maréchal pétain c'est pas un truc
bizarre vous n'avez rien compris à ce
que nous avons bien histoire c'est la
résistance nécessaire
est né ce qu'il avait son mari sa fille
calme pour comprendre et en suède ce
qu'il a dit sur le mérite et la dignité
c'était un collaborateur est un nazi cgv
là
si vous cherchez écoutez et quoi qu'est
ce qu'il a dit alors qu'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire sur pétain peau il avoue le
dire que grâce à la fin à la france
libre de pétain a grâce à vichy il ya
des juifs qui ont pu s'échapper de
france qui fait actuellement est vrai
sont
accusés de ce soir va
pas du tout
entendu les noms juliette pourquoi c'est
un sujet de ce soir pourquoi je vais te
dire que tu avais aussi mais pour moi
c'est pourquoi ce soir 300 juillet
puisque on parler d amour et juif
pratiquant ménard est à dire qu ils
antisémites en france en juin avoir
juges ont séduit rien à voir non rien à
quoi c'est un sujet que ce soit parce
qu'on parle de d'eric zemmour qu'à
chaque fois qu'il arrive dans une ville
c'est compliqué pour les gens qui
l'accueille qaïda non mais c'est
l'ensemble de ce court donc ça fait
partie de ce qu il a dit également donc
jamais vous reconnais que c'est une
provocation ultime aisément qu'il est
pacifié qui peuvent y porte un programme
il boit du hip entretien il porte des
inquiétudes qui inquiète 67% des
français n'est plus au programme cette
année -2 5 points donnez moi c'est moi
j'étais amené quoi
eric zemmour il porte des inquiétudes
qui inquiète on l'a vu 67% des français
67% des français sont inquiets du grand
remplacement donc quand même c'est que
la démocratie ça inquiète choix sang et
or sur des gens il faut bien laisser la
parole à eric zemmour c'est ce qui dit
il parle de ses dublin a tenté pour cent
des
jantes anthracite sondage complet mais
les sondages si ça vous fait chier les
chiffres
se voir de vous laisse les vous je vais
peut-être passer plusieurs groupes de
rock racing
oui je dis non est ce que est ce que ce
que c'est un danger pour l'ordre public
en fait ça parce que ça fait de la
mousse que ça va vous laisser un danger
je veux dire on est habitué maintenant
manifestations aux gens qu'ils se tapent
dessus malheureusement en france a lancé
comme ça les gens sont tellement tendue
pour un oui ou pour un non ils
s'insultent donc aujourd'hui il n'y a
jamais eu une personne non déclarés qui
a eu autant d'intentions de vote donc
quelque part il ya des gens qui l'admiré
il ya des gens qui le détestent alors
vous avez jusqu'à du grand rabbin de
france remportée avec le jean bracq
d'ailleurs il a dit il ya 10 sur eric
zemmour c'est malik des gamertags
j'avais vu juste après me antisémite
certainement raciste évidemment basque a
dit le grand rabbin de france est voulu
répondre et je m'en fous
mais vous c'est maintenant quand on
appelle raciste facho non mais je vous
jure je mens et on met qu'on a besoin
contre eux ou bien je mets tout de même
ça s'en fiche pas en essentiellement les
racines et les intrus france mais
retombé n'ai pas d'argument j'avais bien
sûr vous êtes juste dégoûté parce que
nous allons écouter on pourrait vous
développer
alors oui à 39% non à 60 voix la babine
tous les deux parce que vous êtes super
blog matic donc c'est penny mais elle la
réponse avec lui les mêmes traits de
l'armée et oui on non on pourrait le
comparer à 1 antifa madame nikaïa j'ai
lu ce qu'on va laisser dans la rue
madame oui tous ses potes sont en prison
mais vous aimez madame se désole
incendie secours jeunes en son temps et
ça c'est franchement pénible mais la
réponse à la question eric zemmour est
il un danger pour le public b non parce
que si on dit oui c'est un danger il
faut l'interdire ça veut dire qu'à
chaque personnalité politique qui
déplaira il y aura le même genre de
bordel c'est ce que disait géraldine
pour macron dans certaines villes donc
la démocratie c'est effectivement de
laisser les gens allaient parler d'avoir
des contrats dicter vos des contrôles
initiaux mère juste qu'il voit le bordel